[موسيقى]
سياره
اللون البرتقالي التضامنا مع السكان
الاصليين حيث يستذكرون قصه الطفله في
الرساله التي تعرضت الاتحاد في المدارس
الداخليه في كندا على يد مشرفتها عندما
ارتدت ذات يوم اللون البرتقالي لتقوم
المشرفه بتقطيع قميصها وقص شعرها
150 الف طفل انتزع من اسرهم ووضع في مدارس
دينيه داخليه الزاميه للدراسه بحسب ما
تقول السلطات الكنديه لكن السكان الاصليين
يرون ان الهدف كان طمسه هويتهم
كانت الحياه صعبه عليهم
كيف سيعود اغلبهم اتجه الى الكحول
والمخدرات لنسيان ما حدث له اذا لم تتعامل
معه كطفل كيف سيكون ابا او اما وكيف سيقدم
الحب اذا لم يعطى له
اعتراف علني واعتذار امام الشعب السلطات
الكنديه خصصت يوما للمصالحه والحقيقه عما
بدر منهم والاختراف بان المدارس الداخليه
هي وسيله اباده ثقافيه
[موسيقى]
اعلم ان الاعتذار لن يكفي لانه لن يمحي
الوحده التي شعرت بها ولن يخفف الالم الذي
عنيتم منه ولن يعيد لغتكم وعاداتكم التي
خسرتموها ولن يخفف الوحده
في المدارس الداخليه